hello guys it's Greg the elbe here oh hi
Greg
I'm monnet Vanessa's here and today
we're gonna you know we've shot a couple
videos but I wanted to end on a positive
note from top five unknowns five
creepiest commercials found on YouTube
yeah you know this is like a great way
to get to know women so it's like you
show them something creepy on the
internet when they come into your home
alone and it makes her very comfortable
environment see how much they cry yeah
let's find out you make a woman cry that
means they care we set up a little fun
polling quiz on the amino horror app so
go there and vote if you haven't already
downloaded the app head over to your app
or Play Store and that with the amino
horror app for free exact I was on there
I get a chance to participate a
commercial is a fine method to use when
promoting a product on TV or anywhere
else but these five commercials that
you're about to watch we're a little
different than your average Oh number
five
clowns are supposed to bring joy and
laughter and entertain interviewers
lives in this cringe-worthy television
commercial for post sugar rice the 60s
era commercial involves a rather creepy
wild a cow named wrinkles the green aura
of this video leaves you puzzled and
goosebumps all at the same time we have
no idea what the director was thinking
that message she was trying to send but
we'll leave it to you guys to think
about blame crinkles huh number four
who doesn't love ice cream after
watching this commercial you might
reconsider this disturbing commercial
filmed in Philadelphia for an ice cream
shop most likely destroyed some viewers
appetite for ice cream forever in this
commercial a man appears to be covered
in vanilla ice cream while staring into
the
he begins using a spoon to scoop and eat
the ice cream from the top of his head
never breaking his gaze with the camera
leaving the viewers with the creeps
number three
hey fee is a German company that makes
and sell energy drink they also sell it
in form of gum and even latte in the
early 2000 an advertising agency John
von math made a commercial to promote
the soft energy drink the commercial is
called ghost car it starts off as a
peaceful scene where a car could be seen
driving up the road when suddenly
there's a creepy zombie that pops out of
nowhere a German message that follows of
course once the video hit the YouTube
world in 2005 it went viral the ghost
car video became one of the first viral
videos on YouTube number two neat proper
tires then Ottaway tires is the right
place to go perhaps that should have
been their commercial instead of this
cringy clip that I'm about to show you
Autoweek tires is a tire shop situated
in Japan the company came up with the
idea of creating a commercial to warn
people about the dangers of driving on
icy roads without proper tires the
commercial begins with this bright
caution sign warning people with mental
or physical health issues to refrain
from watching their commercial it then
proceeds to show someone driving through
what appears to be a winter storm when
suddenly the person encounters a woman
with a white robe which she then
suddenly jumps in front of the car she
then holds a laptop with a message
written on number one the message this
commercial clip is creepy and depressing
at the same time the reason why it's at
number one is because of its dark vibe
it radiates the commercial was released
in 1978 in the United Kingdom to warn
young people about the dangers of water
and the consequences it can come with
once an irresponsible behavior is
carried the clip is called
dark and lonely water throughout the
video
there's a grim reaper that follows the
children who are carrying out dangerous
act the tone of the narrator is quite
calm
but yet dark and creepy which brings the
video to another level of creepiness
this branch is weak rocky I don't never
take his way don't forget to vote using
the amino horror app I may post a link
in the description box for the lazy ones
thanks again for watching this video if
you enjoyed it give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to click that subscribe
button to stay updated with our videos 5
unknowns beeps Wow um the one I still
thinking about is [ __ ] that crinkles
the diversity the clown man I've never
liked clowns never never liked clowns
that was like the epitome of evil
looking clown you know it seemed
authentic that wouldn't bother you even
more than the dude eating that ice cream
out of his head the tinted blink at
least mr. krinkle or whatever blinked
yeah yeah I mean I know but mr. krinkle
looked like it was a serial killer true
he also had terrible eyebrows a terrible
eyebrows yeah and I know a thing or two
about eyebrows know that you don't know
about now yeah I mean the ice cream gosh
wait oh no damn it I want to make a joke
about yes don't do it I'm not gonna do
it
gotta protect image here guess what it
is
oh the car commercial with the zombie
popping up I didn't know that was for an
energy drink I didn't realize I was an
actual commercial I didn't eat is just
like a skit on YouTube I thought I was
like some random video someone did yeah
viruses why would they think that is
good huh why would they think any of
these are good well I don't know
especially that last one oh my god I
know I love kids
that's just not you just don't you just
don't do that
it kind of looks like um
me this one when I wake up in the
morning you see yourself in a lot of
people huh oh you know cartoon
characters and Jesus Jesus and uh any
any Denzel movie yeah this guy looks
[ __ ] creepy looks like evil Conan
O'Brien yes
doesn't even Conan O'Brien with food
poisoning yeah oh just out of the shower
I want to do this video but have me Papa
do it yeah
and but say something like you know
interesting it like like crazy our
Father
ha ha ha something religious yeah
something like long and religious and
it's like this is going on way too long
like John 8:12 Johnny 12 yeah oh that's
the one about how Jesus was baptized and
uh in the lake and became a bit that's
super yeah what I love about the tire
one is it has nothing to do with Tigers
no like at least the ice-cream one with
ice cream you know the clown one cereal
this one I'm like there's there's
nothing here at all that resembles the
Tigers and homegirl pulls up a laptop
with the message they don't even know we
don't even know what the message is it
could say don't eat ice cream anymore
for all we know you could say um two for
$5.99 at Carl's jr. I could say you
forgot your jacket yeah you could say hi
my name is Chicka Chicka Slim Shady
that's probably what it says that's most
likely what it says like those that girl
look like a huge Slim Shady thing you
know like though you go to Eminem
concert it mainly looks like a bunch of
demon woman totally and and fat white
guys you don't want to be cool I'm
usually part of that crowd the one with
the Grim Reaper chasing after the kids
so this commercial was released about
the
dangers of water hydration showering and
I don't know what's a third water thing
you do um uh swimming swimming yeah
well yeah that's kind of accurate though
third funny one okay rule of three
commie
the dangers of drowning and swimming
like ah I I guess that's effective that
would make me never want to go swimming
uh that would make me never want to
watch TV ever yeah
I mean what sucks is is about little
kids in danger oh don't do that
none that wins for the number one creepy
yeah you don't do that to little kids
unless they really deserve it
ha ha ha slack they been like acting up
and like you're trying to watch an
episode of house of cards and they just
won't shut up because there's only one
TV here I have a kid and it's four years
old um little Gregory jr. and with yet
well there's a reason he's on with this
apartment right oh yeah he's been
punished oh yeah
I put him in one of those uh you know
those hot little boxes that's filled
with hot water and he has to just
survive for the next 12 hours to prove
his manliness Oh it'll come out a
stronger person what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger right yeah so I
constantly put my kid to the test I
could already see a lot of psychological
trauma ha ha I can already see that he
resents me he's always wondering where
his mama's um she's dead I four years
ago I she took on my french fries
without asking I got a little out of
control next thing you know um period a
body down and then you know Las Vegas
desert did me if it was a sweet potato
fry and interest exact Thank You mo net
that [ __ ] deserves to burn in hell yeah
anyway uh that's not sure I don't I
don't
have people take me too seriously
sometimes yeah yeah I don't have a dead
ex-wife see everyone is gullible
everyone is Milhouse reference to
another video anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the Chanel
listen Finnell yeah another word for
channel I like it now if you're new to
the channel subscribe today become a
reject moan an additional sweet eats
yeah if you want to learn to me
healthier but also not lose that
delicious appetite you can go there
learn from o-net and Jesse yes who
apparently has a boyfriend
oh she does she's so much fun though I
love it it's fun
well if they break up can't because you
read down with me well duh we'll talk it
out I don't mind being a rebound a
reject and a rebound
well his work becomes with the territory
of being a reject I'm a rebound I'm like
the leave am kind of guy ah you know
like oh this girl's hurt I'm gonna go my
master now Greg for a while confuse his
feelings and make him feel emotionally
attached as I need the emotional
attachment that I'm gonna break up with
him there because I'm he's still in love
with not the other one it's happened so
many times
really yeah that's why she's dead well
anyway a watcher